what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
as well as going through the comments
section for follow-up hulks and world
Warhawks a lot of videos that we did
just because of the fact that there were
tie ins for like Captain America vs.
Wolverine and a few others here and
there and a lot of people were asking
for those a lot of folks were asking for
the tie-ins to follow hooks and World
War Hulk so I said sure why not I mean
already past the event we kind of went
to hero kala but hero kala leave was at
a good jumping-off point to basically
say hey we could take a break for a
second or we can go back and grab a few
things that we missed from Kuala folks
the world war hawk so we're gonna go
ahead and we're gonna throw these
tie-ins in and we're gonna start with
Hulk cool now remember during a world of
I guess world war hawks and follow-up
Hawks those of you guys who haven't seen
those videos yet you'll find them down
in the description the Red Hulk had
basically been taken and the gamma
radiation that he'd been storing up was
basically dispersed among the Avengers
the x-man Thor and it just resulted in
really just like all these different
hero is becoming Hulk affine is the best
way I know how to say it but Deadpool
was one of the heroes who was turned
into a Hulk the difference here is that
instead of like staying alongside Red
Hulk and fighting against Red Hulk or
just kind of you know laying waste and
attacking different things instead this
is a Deadpool story and so what would a
Deadpool story be without Deadpool
screwing everything up and that's
exactly what happens
Deadpool grabs his sidekick Bob now for
those of you guys who don't know bob is
like this Hydra agent who's also part of
aim it's like this weird situation but
he's basically like like Deadpool's
Inside Man but it's like the worst
friendship in the history of the world
but Bob also has access to you know Ames
resources which include doctor dooms
time platform now doctor dooms time
platform is a well known established
concept of Marvel Comics it's been
around for quite some time and it's
usually what he uses to jump back and
forth through time but other people use
it too we know what was used or like
Marvel the end when dr. Dave tried to go
back in time and attain absolute power
in the universe it was used during age
of Ultron when the heroes went back in
time or I guess what forward and
backwards in time to try to prevent
Ultron from taking over the world but
with Deadpool here Bob doesn't really
know how to use it effectively and so
he's really just kind of like punching
things in but he sends Deadpool to a
predetermined coordinate and what this
court it turns out to be is you know
back in the days of piracy back when you
know in the image of higher 'its and he
ends up running into black
beard the thing now this is a cool thing
here is because this was actually the
first appearance I guess I think it was
the first appearance of Doctor Doom and
Marvel Comics one of the first things he
did which basically attacked the
Fantastic Four and then make him go back
in time to capture the treasure of
Blackbeard the pirate now the way this
story differs here is that when Ben
Grimm ended up being sent back in time
he was basically you know kind of viewed
as like a leader by these pirates and
ultimately it turned into a situation
where he was he was elevated to becoming
Blackbeard of course you had Reed
Richards he had Johnny Storm who were
kind of like hey man we have to get out
of here when Deadpool arrives he
basically screws this up and so instead
of like the original story when a
tornado came through and it basically
knocked sense back into Ben Grimm and he
ended up going back to his normal self
and then he alongside Johnny Storm Irene
Richards went back to the future instead
Vinny Grimm stays here the other funny
thing too is that when he looks at bed
full of course he tries to attack him
right off the bat but then the tube that
basically form a friendship and so what
they start doing is just start sailing
around the Caribbean robbing everybody
they could possibly find becoming like
this one-two punch of pirates now
another thing here is that as captain
and first mate hopeful and Ben Grimm
actually end up running up on the
British Royal of Royal Navy and the
world Navy
attacks them with a Kraken and so
because of this if all this is happening
Bob is like okay we got to find a way to
get a whole pull out of here because the
idea of hope for basically travelling
back in time is to find Deadpool and
kill himself now of course this creates
all kinds of contradictory issues if you
notice a grandfather paradox how can hug
pool go back in time to kill himself if
he's dead in the past it doesn't make
any sense but this is a Deadpool comic
logic usually never plays a role and so
what happens is that while Bob is trying
to whisk whole pool away he
inadvertently teleports a dinosaur to
his location and actually the he ends up
grabbing him from the Savage Land and so
because this is really just like all
these different organisms these are the
dinosaurs monsters or so on attacking
Ben Grimm and and Deadpool Hulk but they
end up coming out on top they basically
ended up winning here of course it's
it's kind of a weird situation but you
know what we also have is Bob
effectively grabbing them you know being
successful and securing the thing and
benda whole cool and actually ends up
whisking him away to the American West
and in 1873 now again this is a point
when we're still dealing with time
displace with various characters
specifically with Hawkeye but almost
immediately after they show up the
dinosaur just starts attacking people
you know
really knows what's going on but then
suddenly hopeful is whisked away and
hopeful ends up landing where Captain
America and Bucky Barnes were located
now again this is just another example
of him stirring up Tom this is when
things really go awry this is basically
when he starts to kill all the
superheroes and the reason why is
because he's basically just preventing
all their origin stories from happening
that's really all he's doing here and
that's why I smashed up with Captain
America I want you to keep in mind here
is that with Captain America as part of
the Ed Brubaker run ed Roo Baker
basically come back and retcon things of
the original Captain America story it
was Bucky Barnes and Steve Rogers trying
to prevent a plane you know from taking
off and basically attacking the United
States and this particular story the
story of Ed Brubaker it was Bucky Barnes
and Captain America trying to stop a
missile but the fact remains here that
with with hopeful jumping in of course
she's able to prevent the missiles
launch and he saves Bucky Barnes and
Captain America so that means that
Captain America never gets frozen in ice
Bucky Barnes never becomes the Winter
Soldier after falling in the icy waters
again and freezing not only that they
basically reactivate the rocket it takes
off back to Germany and it kills Adolf
Hitler and the Red Skull so now that
entire aspect of history has been
altered that's it that's that's the end
of them so we have Captain America we
have hope pool
we have Bucky Barnes celebrating in
North America but then we find out that
because of hopefuls actions and hanging
out with Ben Grimm as a pirate and
landing in in in the American West in
1873 Ben Grimm had basically become the
first president of the United States the
reason why was because he alongside
whatever forces he was able to muster
attacked the British Royal Army and
started the American Revolution
Blackbeard the pirate Ben Grimm started
the American Revolution they won and he
became president of the first President
of the United States and so from here
again you know the idea is to try to get
Hulk pull through time try to save whole
pool or I guess try to get whole cool to
kill his younger self to kill Deadpool
and so while this is happening he's
basically being sent to all these
different significant eras the first
place he shows up in is Matt Murdock
when Matt Murdock is a kid and he's
going to be hit by this truck filled
with toxic waste hope Poole jumps in the
way stops the truck from hitting Matt
Murdock and he never becomes Deadpool
and following this he prevents the
vehicle
of dr. Stephen strange from flying off
the road which of course stops him from
becoming the sorcerer supreme
he's teleported a he's teleported under
the space shuttle of the Fantastic Four
um and basically prevents that from
being bombarded with cosmic rays hitting
it back to earth he stops Thor from
account at ragga stops Donald lake from
encountering those weird rock monsters
which results in him becoming four for
the very first time he stops Peter
Parker from being bitten by a
radioactive spider he saves Tony Stark
from being shot by bullets which me
which is when he would have been injured
and would have become Iron Man and of
course he keeps Bruce Banner from being
hit by the gamma bomb which prevents him
from becoming the Incredible Hulk
and so basically hope pool has been sent
back in time and in his journey to get
back to the present day or at least get
back to a day or two before the present
day the killers younger self the heat
prevents all the origin stories of the
superheroes he literally prevents all
the superheroes from ever coming into
existence ah that is what he does that's
his legacy now of course eventually he's
sent to to what seems to be you know the
modern day and we have Deadpool in a
strip club pan strippers money for their
services and of course the two of them
start fighting each other now get this
is really funny because you know
Deadpool is Leo fighting hopeful but
he's excited more than anything else
right because you know hopefuls like
look at your future this is your future
this is who you're going to become and
Deadpool's like I become the most badass
Hulk ever like I'm so down with that
which admittedly I would be too but
while all this is happening Bob is
basically met by the arrival of an aim
agent you know one of the guys from
advanced idea mechanics and he was he's
like dude you bone add you literally
screwed up everything like like you're
sitting Hulk back in time it doesn't
work that way you can't just send a
person back in time and change the
present if they go back at Tom and they
alter a fixed point which is to say
something that always happens
universally in every timeline then all
it does is create a divergent universe
you've literally just created an
alternate reality where the Incredible
Hulk basically killed all the
superheroes and so because of this Bob's
like okay well I mean we got to find a
way to bring him back right we got to
find a way to get him back here and so
of course the aim agent is for the most
part able to help him pull this off but
in the meantime while they're trying to
figure it out again it's really just
this idea that Hulk pool is making the
argument that the problem the reason why
he wants to kill Deadpool is because it
doesn't like the idea of killing he
doesn't like the idea of Deadpool going
through and killing people arbitrarily
for contracts or ever the case may be
and so hopefuls trying to prevent those
four happen he's basically to try to
prevent what he considers to be as
darker half now the irony in this is
astounding the fact that that hope pool
doesn't like killing and so the best way
to prevent himself from becoming a
killer is to go back in time and kill
himself
that makes no sense to me but he ends up
being successful anyway he actually ends
up killing Deadpool killing this version
of himself and so what this story does
is it results in you know in hopefully
successfully being brought back to the
modern day to to the current moment and
this effectively just kind of wraps back
around to the end of fall of hoax and
world war halts where we saw we saw Red
Hulk and Bruce Banner working together
to basically take down the intelligence
see and all that kind of good stuff but
if you guys are interested make sure you
guys check out the equatable hulk stuff
down in the description i'm gonna go
ahead and actually throw this video in
in the chronological order so that you
guys can go through watch the videos in
sequence and it'll all still make sense
also there have been a couple people who
have made mention that the videos are
released that the titles for the videos
seem a little off in the Incredible Hulk
playlist I'm not sure they are but if
any of the other guys are having
problems problems of that make sure you
post a comment let me know let me know
if you guys are seeing issues in terms
of the chronology it doesn't seem like
it's right or something along those
lines but if you're new here to comments
explaining she got to the subscribe
button to become part of the Rob port
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah it's a pretty quick
one but again this story wasn't meant to
be super in-depth I couldn't really do a
whole lot of exposition here because
when it comes to Deadpool stories
there's not much deep thought going on
here it's just you're stuck Deadpool's
doing and that's the story and that's
that's pretty much it but it is fun to
cover it is fun to see a horrified
version of Deadpool but we having said
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end and I will catch you all
later please
[Music]